[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
hahlweg
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch norbert lehmann wird ganz viel
sport gutendorf von mir und das sind die
themen von heute
auf der flucht getötet raketen treffen
einen bahnhof in der ost ukraine und
eben kommissionspräsidentin von der
leyen ist zu besuch in kiel
milliardenschwerer stoßdämpfer der bund
schnürt ein hilfspaket für firmen die
von den folgen des ukraine kriegs
betroffen sind
und teil schuldspruch für boris becker
der tennislegende droht im prozess wegen
insolvenzverschleppung eine haftstrafe
dieser 44 kriegstag ist geprägt durch
eine weitere eskalation raketen auf
einen bahnhof voller flüchtlinge im
osten der ukraine 50 menschen sterben
darunter fünf kinder fast 100 werden
verletzt präsident selensky wirft
russland grenzenlose bösartigkeit vor
moskau dagegen beschuldigt die ukraine
den angriff verübt zu haben volker
dutschek
für tausende ist der bahnhof seit tagen
der aufbruchs ort in eine welt ohne
bomben und angst auch heute sie wollen
weg aus kramer tors denn hier wird
womöglich bald krieg seien
gegen halb elf ist für viele familien
nichts mehr wie es war zwei raketen
schlagen plötzlich ein dutzende menschen
sind sofort tot überall trümmer schärpen
blut eine bombe mit streumunition da
sind sich augenzeugen sicher belege
fehlen aber noch autos sind auf dem
bahnhofsvorplatz explodiert
ich war kurz zigaretten kaufen dann die
bomben als ich zum auto zurückkam da oma
tod ich bin losgerannt und habe versucht
anderen zu helfen
mehr als 150.000 einwohner zählt die
stadt im osten hier kontrollieren die
ukraine noch das geschehen doch moskau
will das ganze gebiet von donetsk und
lugansk
vor dem bahnhof liegen die überreste
einer rakete mit der russischen
aufschrift für unsere kinder moskau
weist jede verantwortung zurück unsere
armee nutzt diese art von raketen nicht
zudem haben heute keine einsätze in
krems statt gefunden oder waren in
kartons geplant der kreml behauptete
gegenzug der raketentyp werde nur von
der ukrainischen armee verwendet auch
hier fehlen die beweise
verabscheuungswürdig nennt die eu
kommissionspräsident innenangriff ursula
von der leyen ist heute mit ihrer
delegation in kiew als zeichen der
unterstützung im gepäck neue sanktionen
gegen russland aus ukrainischer sicht
allerdings nach wie vor zu wenig um den
krieg zu beenden
anne gellinek
ortstermin in butscher dem ort an dem
die gräuel des krieges in der ukraine
sichtbar wurden eu-kommissionspräsident
in von der leyen steht plötzlich an
einem massengrab deutlich schockiert
zusammen mit dem eu außenbeauftragten
josef pröll will sie sich einen eindruck
verschaffen darüber was hier geschah
während klingt das undenkbare ist hier
passiert
wir haben das grausame gesicht von
putins armee gesehen wir haben die
rücksichtslosigkeit und kaltherzigkeit
gesehen mit der sie diese stadt besetzt
haben
gestern nacht waren von der leyen und
borel zehn stunden lang mit dem zug aus
polen in die ukrainische hauptstadt
gereist wo sie am späten nachmittag auch
mit dem ukrainischen präsidenten
selensky zusammen
sie sind willkommen frau präsidentin
sagt vladimir selensky zur begrüßung die
europäer haben ein geschenk mitgebracht
der ebenfalls mitgereiste slowakische
premierminister kündigte an sein land
wolle der ukraine das s 300 raketen
abwehrsystem sowjetischer bauart
überlassen so abwehr russische angriffe
außerdem will die eu der ukraine weitere
500 millionen euro zur unterstützung der
streitkräfte zur verfügung stellen in
butter hatten die europäer auch
versprochen dass sie der ukraine bei der
aufklärung der verbrechen mit eigenen
ermittlern helfen werden der besuch hier
ein symbol ein zeichen dass die eu an
der seite der ukraine stehe und die
ganze welt mit butter trauert
fragen wie katrin eigendorf in kiew
welche bedeutung hat dieser besuch der
eu-spitze für die ukraine
eine sehr große dieser besuch stand ja
nicht nur unter dem eindruck von
butscher sondern vor allem unter dem
eindruck von dem was heute in grammatik
passiert ist und ursula von der leyen
hat die pressekonferenz damit begonnen
dass sie das als abscheuliche tat
russlands verurteilt hat und sie wirkte
wirklich sehr emotional insgesamt war
das treffen zwischen selensky und ursula
von der leyen ein sehr finde ich
emotionales treffen rösler von der leyen
ist sehr weit gegangen indem sie dem
ukrainischen präsidenten zugesichert hat
dass die eu 100 prozent an der seite der
ukraine stünde dass man den beitrag
beitrittsprozess für eine eu
mitgliedschaft des landes der
normalerweise jahre dauert bereit ist
auf wochen zu verkürzen und dass sie
sich da voll dafür einsetzen würde was
ich auch sehr wichtig fand ursula von
der leyen hat susi lenski gesagt dass
die ukraine hier den krieg europas aus
fechtet und dass sie alles tun wird und
dass europa alles tun wird um die
ukraine in diesem krieg zu unterstützen
das ist schon sehr viel und sie hat auch
noch mal versichert dass die ukraine zur
europäischen familie gehört sicher
präsident selensky dann auf dieser
pressekonferenz gefragt ob er zufrieden
ist mit den ergebnissen
er ist ein bisschen aus hat ein bisschen
ausweichend geantwortet aber schon
insgesamt den eindruck vermittelt dass
das für die ukraine ein kleiner
fortschritt ist in den beziehungen zu
europa und dass dieser rückhalt den
ursula von der leyen hiermit ausgedrückt
hat für die ukraine sehr wichtig ist
dankeschön katrin eigendorf live aus
kiew
mehr als
320.000 flüchtlinge aus der ukraine
haben hierzulande bereits zuflucht
gefunden der bund hat den ländern und
zugesagt einen großteil der kosten dafür
zu tragen insgesamt zwei milliarden euro
die geflüchteten erhalten den gleichen
status wie anerkannte asylbewerber
damit stehen ihnen die leistungen wie
hartz iv empfängern zu alexander pohl
berichtet jeden tag kommen am münchner
hauptbahnhof flüchtlinge aus der ukraine
an allein gestern waren es weit über 300
zumeist frauen und kinder nach einem
beschluss von bund und ländern sollen
sie künftig genauso unterstützt werden
wie anerkannte asylbewerber ab dem
ersten sechsten diesen jahres soll es so
sein dass die
flüchtlinge die vertriebenen aus der
ukraine die grundsicherung für
arbeitsuchende beziehen können außerdem
erhalten sie eine arbeitserlaubnis
werden krankenversichert und haben
anspruch auf kindergeld und deutschkurse
über 320.000 flüchtlinge aus der ukraine
sind mittlerweile in deutschland
angekommen an den kosten für ihre
integration wird sich der bund nun
beteiligen 500 millionen euro für die
unterbringung bekommen die kommunen
weitere 500 millionen erhalten die
länder für bislang entstandene kosten
für gesundheit und kinderbetreuung zeit
der bund noch einmal eine milliarde euro
die länder alles in allem zufrieden in
der summe ist es vertretbar und
alle zugestimmt es ist wichtig dass wir
die menschen schnell aufnehmen städte
und gemeinden fordern aber weitere
anstrengungen
es müssen willkommens klassen in den
schulen errichtet werden in kitas müssen
in sehr kurzer zeit ausgebaut werden all
das wird natürlich auch den kommunen
noch mal erheblich ist an fordern
menschenrechtsorganisationen begrüßten
die maßnahmen von bund und ländern sie
fordern aber dass diese künftig für alle
asylbewerber gelten sollen
zwei milliarden euro das sind wie eben
gehört die zuschüsse des bundes für die
flüchtlingshilfe
insgesamt werden die folgen des krieges
den bundeshaushalt mit 24 milliarden
euro zusätzlich belasten das schätzt
finanzminister lindner auch viele
unternehmen sind betroffen sie sollen
mit bis zu fünf milliarden euro
unterstützt werden patricia wiedemeier
gemeinsam verkündeten am mittag der
finanz und der wirtschaftsminister das
nicht nur die bürger sondern auch die
unternehmen die durch den krieg in der
ukraine in mitleidenschaft gezogen
werden entlastet werden sollen das was
wir als paket ihnen vorstellen ist ein
wirtschaftspolitischer stoßdämpfer er
federt herten ab verhindert struktur
brüche aber erlöst marktkräfte nicht auf
und er geht verantwortungsbewusst mit
dem geld der steuerzahlerinnen und
steuerzahler um vor allem die hohen
energiepreise bereiten vielen
unternehmen probleme kurzfristig
liquidität sicherzustellen ein ziel der
regierung geplant sind unter anderem ein
kostenzuschuss für energieintensive
unternehmen ca 5 milliarden euro kredite
der förderbank kfw circa 7 milliarden
und kredite für firmen die von energie
börsen abhängen bis zu 100 milliarden
euro ein umfassendes maßnahmenpaket
umfassend heißt allerdings nicht und das
ist nicht möglich dass jede härte
weggenommen wird das jeder verlust jeder
mehr euro für energie beispielsweise
ausgeglichen wird wir werden also die
unternehmen und die privatpersonen die
bürgerinnen und bürger dieses landes
eine last zu tragen habe für die
opposition der richtige weg unternehmen
müssten dringend entlastet werden
deswegen kommt es vor allem darauf an
dass das paket schnell umgesetzt wird es
muss schneller sein als beispielsweise
das zweite energie entlastungspaket das
bisher über die ankündigung vor nicht
hinausgekommen ist genau das sicherten
beide minister heute zu schnell soll es
gehen aber auch das betonten sie die
hilfen seien zeitlich begrenzt
eine große mehrheit der deutschen
befürwortet härtere sanktionen gegen
russland im aktuellen zdf-politbarometer
sprechen sich 77 prozent für
verschärfungen aus 18 prozent dagegen öl
und gasimporte aus russland wollen 28
prozent sofort stoppen die meisten sind
aber dafür sie erst zu beenden wenn die
versorgung anderweitig gesichert ist das
ausführliche politbarometer gibt es wie
immer im heute-journal ab 22 uhr schon
jetzt finden sie in unserem zdf heute
app alle zahlen und umfragewerte auch
zum wegfall der korona maßnahmen eine
herbe niederlage so bezeichnet
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach die
gescheiterte impfpflicht ein neuer
anlauf sei unwahrscheinlich
eine impfpflicht wird es im herbst wohl
neue beschränkungen geben müssen bis hin
zur lok downs schätzen ärzte zwar sinkt
die sieben tage incidents weiter liegt
aber immer noch bei rund 1.100 81 und
weiterhin sind 19,5 millionen menschen
in deutschland nicht geimpft regis land
berichtet am tag danach ein
zerknirschter
bundesgesundheitsminister die von ihm
geforderte impfpflicht fand gestern im
bundestag eine zustimmung einen erneuten
anlauf soll es laut bundeskanzler
entgegen seiner überzeugung nicht geben
es hat eine klare und auch bittere
niederlage für alle impfpflicht
befürworter gegeben das ist auch für
mich der fahren natürlich weil ich habe
mich sehr intensiv und aus überzeugung
für die einführung einer allgemeinen
pflicht eingesetzt 76 prozent der
bevölkerung doppelt geehrt für
lauterbach immer noch zu wenig den
krankenhäusern jedoch droht derzeit
keine überlastung mit kurve patienten
vielmehr plagt sie der personalausfall
pfleger und ärzte infiziert obwohl qua
gesetz hier alle geimpft sind seit mitte
februar stehen wieder immer mehr ampeln
unserer intensivstation auf rot derzeit
knapp 40 prozent der grund im moment ist
vor allen dingen fehlendes und dieses
mal vor allen dingen erkranktes personal
die gute nachricht der höhepunkt der
omicron welle sei überwunden doch der
minister sorgt sich bereits um den
herbst dann läuft das
infektionsschutzgesetz aus dass er auf
einen basisschutz gestutzt hatte und
kündigt an wir können mit dem was wir
jetzt wissen mit großer
wahrscheinlichkeit nicht ohne eine
masken pflicht zum beispiel in den
herbst hinein gehen eine bittere woche
für karl lauterbach der weiterhin
unbeirrt fürs impfen wirbt nicht wissend
welchen lauf dass gruner virus nehmen
wird
nach frankreich wo übermorgen
präsidentschaftswahl ist genauer gesagt
deren erster teil denn zunächst wird
sich entscheiden wer in die stichwahl in
zwei wochen kommt ziemlich sicher sind
dass amtsinhaber emanuel makro und die
rechtspopulistin marine le pen alle
anderen bewerber scheinen abgeschlagen
der ausgang aber ist absolut offen denn
makro liegt nur noch knapp vor seiner
härtesten konkurrentinnen christel haas
berichtet
da hängen sie die kandidaten nicht auf
plakaten sondern auf socken wenn der
wahlkampf so leichtfüßig wäre er wird
begleitet von corona und dem ukraine
krieg als krisenmanager erhielt emanuel
makro gute umfragewerte doch dieser
effekt ist vorbei bei seinem einzigen
großen wahlkampfauftritt warnt er davor
seine gegner zu unterschätzen
das ist der kampf des fortschritts gegen
die abschottung es ist der kampf des
patriotismus und von europa gegen die
nationalisten
[Musik]
denn sie ist ihm laut umfragen dicht auf
den fersen die rechtspopulistin marin
lippen sie verspricht den franzosen mehr
kaufkraft ist euro skeptisch und will
die zuwanderung stark begrenzen
frankreich wird entweder in einem großen
global ist ischen magma untergehen mit
der eu als auftakt oder unsere nation
besteht weiter als sicherer hafen für
die franzosen
dennoch wird sie fast schon als gemäßigt
wahrgenommen denn der noch viel rechte
ericsson hat noch radikalere positionen
und noch ein kandidat macht sich
hoffnung diesmal auf dem linken rand so
lück manager er will eine neue republik
gründen und raus aus der nato immerhin
über 40 prozent der franzosen wollen am
sonntag für einen kandidaten am rechten
oder linken hand stimmen
für die stichwahl sagen die umfragen
eine neuauflage des duells makro ident
voraus dieses mal aber ist die
rechtspopulisten stärker als noch vor
fünf jahren es könnte also eng werden
für makro diese wahl ist für ihn alles
andere als ein durchmarsch
nach dem gestrigen anschlag in tel aviv
mit drei toten hat israels
ministerpräsident benjamin
bewahrend gestern abend feierte ein
palästinenser laut polizei in einer bar
in die menge er wurde von
sicherheitskräften erschossen es war der
vierte anschlag in rund zwei wochen
insgesamt wurden 13 menschen getötet
und jetzt noch was in eigener sache hat
die chefetage im zdf ändert sich und
wird deutlich weiblicher bettina
schausten übernimmt am ersten oktober
die chefredaktion
programmdirektorin mit nadine bilke der
verwaltungsrat stimmte heute den
vorschlägen von intendant norbert
himmler zu susanne gelhard hat details
es sind zwei erfolgreiche zdf frauen die
künftig ganz oben mitbestimmen ein
starkes team für ein starkes zdf so der
intendant bettina schausten und nadine
bilke stehen für exzellenten
journalismus aber auch für ein
innovatives programm management mit der
komplettierung der geschäftsleitung
können wir nun gemeinsam am ziel
arbeiten dass wir für die ganze
gesellschaft ein ausgezeichnetes
öffentlich rechtliches programm machen
und das für alle aus spiel wege den
sender zdfneo leitet nadine birkel seit
2008 10 nach langer erfahrung im bereich
digitale medien mit neuentwicklungen und
serien fürs junge publikum
fernsehen das ist natürlich immer noch
ein linearer kanal das ist sehr sehr
wichtig gleichzeitig müssen wir aber
verstärkt auf die mediathek setzen auf
social media und auf die interaktion mit
unserem publikum auf diesem weg ist das
zdf bereits unterwegs und diesen weg
möchte weiter gehen guten abend was
bettina schausten ist als chefin der
aktuellen programme und moderatorin von
nachrichten wahl und was nun sendungen
dem publikum seit vielen jahren bekannt
es steht für qualitätsjournalismus und
gerade in diesen zeiten von krieg und
krise zeigen wir glaube ich was wir
leisten können ein attraktives
informationsangebot jetzt auch ins netz
zu transferieren für jüngere menschen
ist die zukunftsaufgabe auf die freue
ich mich und nehme sie gerne an ab
oktober stehen dann drei frauen und drei
männer an der spitze des zdf
boris becker sei naiv aber unschuldig
sagt sein verteidiger
die geschworenen in london sehen das
anders sie sind überzeugt dass der
ehemalige tennis star sein vermögen im
insolvenzverfahren teilweise bewusst
verschleiert hat dem 54 jährigen drohen
jetzt bis zu sieben jahre haft aus
london yasin herrlein
beim verlassen des gerichtsgebäudes
heute nachmittag verrät boris beckers
gesicht nicht wie im zumute war die drei
wochen verhandlungen vor dem server
crown court in london hatten der
öffentlichkeit noch einmal das
turbulente leben des tennis stars vor
augen geführt beispiel anklagepunkt 16
das verbergen des pokals seines ersten
bündigen sieges 1985 vor den
insolvenzverwaltern in diesem fall
befand die jury becker für nicht
schuldig in vier von 24 anklagepunkten
allerdings schon darunter die
gravierenden tatbestände der nicht
offenlegung von immobilien und aktien
werten und die verschleierung von
schulden die staatsanwältin warf becker
vor die insolvenzverwalter absichtlich
getäuscht zu haben und verwies auf
dessen frühere verurteilung wegen
steuerhinterziehung in deutschland
beckers verteidiger argumentierte sein
mandant habe sich auf sein tennis
konzentrieren wollen und sei
hoffnungslos überfordert gewesen im
umgang mit geld die bemessung des
strafmaßes obliegt nun der richterin und
wird am 29 april bekanntgegeben becker
droht eine gefängnisstrafe von bis zu
sieben jahren
jetzt zur fußball-europa-league norbert
da sind die frankfurt fans in ganz aus
dem häuschen nach dem viertelfinal
hinspielen war ja auch ein bärenstarker
auftritt der eintracht eigentlich so wie
immer wenn es gegen die ganz großen geht
und wie immer fantastisch unterstützt
vom heimischen publikum barcelona
schwächelte konnte aber dank eines
einzigen geniestreichs zum 1 1 der
niederlage knappe drinnen das
unentschieden fühlt sich an wie ein sieg
die eintracht bietet ihren fans einen
großen kampf gegen den fünfmaligen
champions league gewinner und geht
verdient kurz nach der pause in führung
knauf gelingt ein traumtor
technisch perfekt und zu platziert
vertreter stegen gänsehaut atmosphäre in
der voll besetzten arena ausgelöst durch
den erst 20 jahre alten ansgar knauf
heute gibt es keinen wermutstropfen
sondern nur ein großes großes kompliment
an die spieler für diese herausragende
leistung
dort barcelona zeigt was sein spiel
schon immer ausgezeichnet hat eine
direkt kombination mit ferraris als
letzter station der ausgleich nach gelb
rot für total bringt frankfurt das remis
auch mit zehn spielern über die zeit ein
magischer abend und ein passender
vorgeschmack auf das rückspiel in einer
woche im riesigen stadion von barcelona
ebenfalls 1 1 endete das europa league
viertelfinal hinspiel der leipziger
gegen bergamo die starken gäste aus
italien gingen in der 17 minute durch
luis muriel in führung in der 58 minute
scheiterte der leipziger ein tresor mit
einem foulelfmeter am berger muss
torwart woran muss so kurz danach das
eigentor von atalanta durch david da
costa in der 58 minute das den sachsen
immerhin noch das remis bescherte
das dfb sportgericht hat den einspruch
des sc freiburg nach dem wechselfehler
der bayern zurückgewiesen bei dem
münchner für zu einzig vergangenen
samstag in freiburg hatte der fcb für
wenige sekunden mit zwölf spielern auf
dem feld gestanden die verantwortung
dafür so das urteil des dfb leger aber
nicht bei den bayern der wechsel fehler
seien vielmehr folge eines schuldhaften
verhaltens des schiedsrichters
freiburg hat übrigens darauf verzichtet
einspruch einzulegen der bayern sieg ist
damit sozusagen besiegelt auch das ist
gut danke schön norbert witte noch ist
es draußen ungemütlich mit regen und
schnee wie es weitergeht sagt uns gleich
aus dem terni christian sievers begrüßt
sie im heute schon einmal um 10 wir
wünschen ihm ein schönes wochenende
danke für ihr interesse und bis morgen
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
schon genannt und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter in den nächsten stunden gibt
es noch kräftigen schneefall vor allem
den mittelgebirgen und regen das
verabschiedet sich allmählich nach süden
aber morgen kommt noch einmal kalt luft
von nordwesten her dann bilden sich
schauer und gewitter und die ziehen
ebenfalls südwärts weiter aber das hoch
hier ganz im westen dehnt sich
allmählich aus und in den nächsten tagen
ab montag wird es deutlich ruhiger und
freundlicher in der nacht ist es aber
noch ziemlich durchwachsen im süden
teils mit sturm regen in den höheren
lagen schnee in den mittelgebirgen
ebenfalls da bis zu zehn zentimeter
neuschnee und es kann sogar bis ins
flachland runter schneiden in der mitte
in den frühstunden bilden sich ganz im
norden gewitter bei tiefsten
temperaturen von minus 1 grad in der
eifel und 5 grad richtung bayern und
morgen im tagesverlauf also schauer und
gewitter die ziehen allmählich
südostwärts im südwesten macht sich
schon der hohen luftdruck bemerkbar und
die sonne kommt häufiger hervor die
höchsten temperaturen von vier bis elf
grad in den nächsten tagen vor allem
dann am sonntag noch schauer und im
südwesten sonnenschein bei 6 bis 13 grad
danach wird es wärmer dienstag bis 22
grad ein schöner abend